welcome to this video on algorithmic
persuasion with evidence
i'm martin hofer and this is joint work
with parson manoraxi
and alex somas
so in this work we study
an elementary game of persuasion between
the sender and the receiver
so persuasion is a prominent topic in
economics
and usually you have an agent that has
information about the state of the world
and another agent who can make a
decision so here s
the sender has information about the
state of nature and
r is the decision maker and now the goal
is
to influence decision maker to reveal
information to disclose information in a
way
to influence the decision maker to make
a decision in one own favor
so here we study an elementary version
of this
and the sender wants to persuade the
receiver
to change the status quo so examples of
this could be for instance the sender is
an attorney
and wants to convince a judge to convict
the defendant
or the sender is a job candidate and
wants to convince
firm to hire her or maybe the sender is
a consultant
and wants to convince another company to
acquire a new product
so the incentive or the preference of
the sender is pretty clear here
he wants that the receiver changed the
status quo
on the other hand the receiver wants to
make a correct decision in a sense
so the state of the world is comes in
one of two classes
so either acceptable or rejectable where
acceptable means
the change of the status quo is good
so the defendant is guilty the job
candidate is good we should hire here
or the new product is great should
acquire the new product
or rejectable in which case it's not
good to change the status quo
right so this is an elementary game
very elementary very basic so the
receiver just has two actions
except reject the sender just wants the
receiver to do
a single action all the time no matter
what the state of the world is
and certainly you could envision more
complex games
and more complex scenarios have also
been studied in the economic literature
so let's make things a little bit more
formal here so the state of the world is
drawn according to a given probability
distribution d
and these public knowledge for both
agents
now the sender wants the receiver to
accept no matter what
and the receiver wants to make a correct
decision so he wants to accept if the
state of the world is acceptable and
otherwise he wants to reject
now what do the agents do they determine
a strategy
or a scheme and the sender
determines a signaling scheme to
disclose information about the state of
the world
and the receiver getting this
information then determines what to do
so he determines an action scheme that
maps
the information that he gets the
messages that he gives
to an action so
the sender has the information the
sender sees what the state of the world
is he sees
or she sees her own qualifications here
maybe in this job market example
and sends a signal so sends maybe grades
or
a message to convince the receiver that
the status quo should be changed that
for instance she should be hired
the receiver does not know the state of
the world but he knows the distribution
and he knows what the sender is doing
and what the sender is saying
so he receives the signal knows how the
signal is is generated and then takes an
action
based on his action scheme okay final
utilities
according to the preferences of the
agents utility
of the sender is always one if the
receiver accepts
zero otherwise utility of the receiver
is one if he accepts and the state of
the world is acceptable
it's one if he rejects and the state of
the world is rejectable and zero
otherwise
right so that's a very elementary game
and
you're welcome to take a minute and stop
the video and think about
how this game would be played what would
be in equilibrium what would the
agents do so it's very simple now what
complicates matters in our scenario
is the following restrictions that
signals are not arbitrary
so the agents cannot send arbitrary
messages but here we consider
persuasion with evidence as studied by
glaze and rubenstein
in econometrica in 2004 where each state
of the world
comes with certain evidence that cannot
be forged
and now i can reveal part of the
evidence or i can
choose not to do so as a sender so this
evidence could be
like grades test scores maybe an
academic scenario papers
uh or maybe if you have a product then
maybe there's experimental results
or things like this on the performance
of this product on the performance of
this tool maybe
and this is what you can disclose to the
receiver
so more formally we have a set of states
of the world
each state of the world comes with a
probability from the prior and the label
whether it's acceptable or rejectable
here
acceptable i marked it in green
then we have possible signals these are
the collections of evidence that can be
revealed to the receiver so these are
the signals
and then we have this state signal graph
that
indicates in which state of the world
can i send which signal
and this is the input to our problem so
this is the restriction we're given we
cannot send arbitrary signals in any
state of the world
but we have to respect this evidence
condition that we have to give concrete
evidence
on the state of the world okay
so now in this case what would the
sender do the sender now needs to
determine
to which evidence to send in which state
of the world
so this could be for instance a
signaling scheme for the sender here he
sends this signal here in this state of
the world he sends also this signal
then here in this state of the world he
mixes 50 50
with the middle signal and the right
signal and then here for the right state
of the world he sends the middle signal
all right okay this would be a signaling
scheme then the receiver would come one
would see these signals and would
determine hmm
so what am i going to do now all right
so for instance if i get this left
signal
what's my preference what should i be
doing and
here we can see okay if i get this
signal i get this signal
in 30 of the cases then 20 percent it's
this state of the world 10
at this state of the world so in two two
thirds
of the cases when i get this signal it's
a rejectable state of nature
so my best response as a receiver here
would obviously
be to reject because i would be correct
two-thirds of the time
same reasoning for this one here this
signal is sent
half of the time so in 0.5
of the time we send the signal and then
with
20 it's this state with 30 is this state
so and three-fifths of the time is a
rejectable state two-fifth of the time
is an acceptable state
so here also the best response would be
to reject
then for this state for this signal here
it's clear that it's only been issued
when this state of nature is there so
here obviously the best response is to
accept
all right so this would be the answer of
the receiver here
all right so now given this
classification of the receiver given
this action scheme of the receiver
the sender says well am i going to am i
going to stick to my signaling scheme or
is there a better way to to signal
now given that the receiver does this
the incentive of the senders of course
to maximize the probability that
the receiver plays accept now here for
these two states of the world
an accept is unreachable because both
incident signals are being rejected by
the receiver
for these two states of the world there
is actually an acceptable signal
here which is this one so the natural
incentive would be
to maximize the probability that this
signal here is issued
and indeed this would be your best
response here
and it also keeps the preference of the
receiver so here the receiver sticks to
rejecting here he is
indifferent because this signal is never
issued so
we can assume that he also picks reject
here and then here he
sticks with acceptance because the
probability mass coming from this
acceptable
state is larger than the one coming from
the rejectable state
okay this would be a sequential
equilibrium here
and the sender utility would be 0.7
because 70 percent of the time this
signal here send is being accepted the
receiver utility would be
0.6 because he's correct 60 of the time
so 40 percent of the time here
right and then 20 over here uh so
this is how he sort of manages to to
correctly identify the label of the
state of nature
it's not the only equilibrium there
would be another equilibrium like this
for instance
here the sender simply sends always this
middle signal
then the receiver is indifferent it's 50
50
between accept and reject so we could
assume that he always plays except for
all these signals so he always chooses
to accept action
that of course makes the sender happy
now everything's always accepted here
receivers correct 50 of the time but
this is also
the best you can achieve given the
signaling scheme
right so the equilibrium is not
necessarily unique and there's different
equilibria with different values for
sender and receiver
okay so that's what we study in this
paper and in particular we study this
from a computational perspective
so the goal is to find a pair that's a
sequential equilibrium
then in addition to this equilibrium
problem there are other
versions of this game that have been
studied in the literature in particular
ones with commitment power
so in the economics literature a common
assumption in the area of bayesian
persuasion is that the sender has
commitment power
and he commits to a signaling scheme in
advance
and then the receiver best responds to
it but sim
because he has committed in advance he's
not
best responding to the receiver directly
rather
he's anticipating the best response of
the receiver
so in this sense becomes a buy level
optimization problem where the sender
tries to optimize his signaling scheme
taking into account the subsequent best
response of the receiver
same goes for the receivers of the
receiver's commitment power he commits
to an action scheme in advance
and then the send the best response by
presenting a signaling scheme
and then the receiver has this bi-level
optimization problem where he tries to
find a good action scheme
anticipating the best response of the
sender
now there's an endless debate in
economics literature where these
commitment assumptions are actually
justified
i think there are examples where these
sound plausible
so for instance if you think of an
attorney
who designs his signaling scheme who
designs his uh
his accusation strategy taking into
account
the best response or the the the the um
the behavior of the judge that could be
modeled by a
persuasion persuasion problem with
commitment power on the sender
if you think of a company who says okay
here is criteria based on which we
would hire a new job candidate and now
the candidate
tries to find evidence or grades or
test scores in order to meet these
criteria
that might be a case where we have the
commitment power on the receiver
so but in general like i said there is
debate
uh when and whether these can be applied
but here we study these problems from a
computational
perspective we're not necessarily going
into details
about like economic uh details of this
this application okay so
what can we say about this um
first thing is equilibria a sequential
equilibrium can be computed in
polynomial time
in general so you give me an instance of
the this persuasion problem with
evidence
and then there's a polynomial time
algorithm to compute the sequential
equilibrium
so i didn't flash this out here
in the context of this video so the main
takeaway from these four lines
is that we have a max flow based
technique
that iteratively uh determines
whether signals should be accepted or
rejected
and computes corresponding signaling and
action schemes
if you want to know more i'm happy to
answer your questions by email or come
to me
during the conference then we can talk
about this
if we look at these commitment power
variants
turns out that both agents can
substantially improve the utility
over the one obtained in an equilibrium
so
commitment power actually has a benefit
to
can have a substantial benefit to both
sender and receiver
to illustrate this here two examples so
here is a scenario
with two states of the world one is
accepted one is rejectable two
possible signals and the signal
state graph like this now suppose the
sender is commitment power and
suppose he commits to this signaling
strategy
then what is the receiver doing the
receiver sees on the left side it's 50
50 here for this signal 50 50 for this
signal obviously it should be rejected
because there's only rejectable state of
nature behind it
so this would be a best response of the
receiver where here we always assume tie
breaking in favor of the sender
to avoid messing here with small
epsilons to make strict preferences
so here for the for the sender
commitment we always assume that
the receiver breaks ties in favor of the
sender
which here of course means that he would
pick except he could also play reject
would have the same utility but tie
breaking in favor of sender means that
he's
accepting this signal
what's the utility of the utility of the
sender here is 0.8 obviously because in
80
of the time the receiver accepts but
as can be easily seen this is not an
equilibrium
because here there an accept signal so
obviously the sender has an incentive
to send this signal as often as possible
essentially all the time i mean he can
send the signal all the time
but if he sends the signal all the time
then of course the receiver would say
okay
now sixty percent of the time i'm
getting a rejectable state so i'd rather
pick action reject here
and indeed by applying this reasoning we
can see that every equilibrium in this
instance
uh has the receiver reject both signals
so in every equilibrium
all signals will be rejected the
receiver always plays reject
so the utility of the sender is zero
so here we see that the sender has a
massive
advantage if he enjoys commitment power
i mean the ratio here between these two
utilities is unbounded but also in terms
of absolute difference it's a pretty
substantial improvement
similar observation for the receiver now
here is an instance where we have
again two states of the world two
signals the the state signal graph is a
little bit different
and now suppose the receiver commits to
this action scheme
then the sender tries to maximize the
probability the receiver
accepts but given this restriction in
the graph up here
that's the best you can do and turns out
that this
is also an equilibrium right so this
gives the perfect information perfect
classification for the receiver
so he perfectly identifies the
acceptable and rejectable states
but also it's an equilibrium so if you
if you see then of course the receiver
is happy
and the sender's playing a best response
so here we also have an equilibrium
that's actually a general result by
glacier and rubenstein
that the optimal strategy for the
receiver with commitment
is also part of an equilibrium so
there's always an equilibrium
in which the receiver plays his optimal
strategy with commitment
what about the worst equilibrium so this
of course other equilibria
here's another equilibrium the sender
simply sends this signal here all the
time
and the receiver always rejects it's
easy to see that this is
both of these things are best responses
so that's an equilibrium and here the
receivers only correct
50 of the time so this utility is 0.5
and so this gives a factor to
improvement with commitment over the
worst outcome without commitment
and this is actually tight so we prove
this in the paper that the factor of two
is the
the worst case for this ratio okay
so punchline here is the sender can
improve
possibly substantially the receiver can
also improve by a factor of two up to a
factor of two
with commitment power so let's study
these commitment power versions let's
see what we can
we can we can show for that
um okay so in the paper we first study
the general scenario
of these two problems and it turns out
that persuasion
is in terms of approximation
the harder problem i would say so we
have an upper bound on the approximation
ratio of
o of n but we can also show that this is
independent set heart so it's n to the
one minus epsilon hard for any constant
epsilon
the delegation version where the
receiver has commitment power
there's an upper bound of two and
there's a lower bound of two minus
epsilon
in approximability of two minus epsilon
for any constant epsilon
okay so this is these upper bounds these
algorithms they're really simple
and turns out that asymptotically they
have the optimal approximation ratio in
the general case
so even though this scenario seems very
elementary from the outset
the restriction to evidence can make
this pretty hard
this problem so we also studied
most structured cases where we have for
instance a unique acceptable state or a
unique rejectable state
these cases allow much more positive
news
so for both of these scenarios with
unique acceptable state or in each
rejectable state
you can solve the delegation problem in
polynomial time
uh for the unique accepts and persuasion
we have repeaters and strong np hardness
unique rejects can be solved in
polynomial time also for persuasion
and then there is a condition termed
foresight which was
introduced by share in theoretical
economics in 2014 and
i don't have time to go into the details
of what
instances with foresight satisfy
what's the structural condition here but
that's
actually a condition that can be applied
here to you
unique rejects so you reject is a
special case of instances with foresight
so this algorithm here is actually a
consequence of a result proof by share
the algorithm by share is also a max
flow based algorithm
but for persuasion it's not useful so
for persuasion even instances with
foresight
can be very hard to approximate
so we also studied restrictions on the
state of natures some particular degree
restrictions
so these restrictions don't really make
the persuasion problem any
easier but they have an impact on the
delegation problem
so here degree two states means that
every state of nature we only have two
possible signals
uh for degree d says it's a natural
extension to degree d
degree one except means every acceptable
state has
degree one so for every acceptable state
there's a unique signal to send degree
one rejects for every rejectable state
unique signal
for degree two states we have this 1.1
approximation apx hardness the 3d states
we have
a sort of progression that
goes to two as d increases
degree one accepts is again a special
case of this foresight condition
and for degree one rejects we have apx
hardness and we can show the lower bound
in terms of inapproximability
but the upper bounds improved upper
bounds especially for delegation is an
open problem
i can't go into detail on all of these
results
so that's why i focus will focus on one
of them which is this 1.1 approximation
here for degree 2 states
okay so degree 2 states every state is
connected to at most two signals
so here's an example and now what we do
here is we develop a new representation
so we say signals are vertices and
states of natures become edges so we
turn each of these
states of natures here into an edge
between the corresponding signals
and these new edges are of course
weighted by the probability that the
the state of nature is drawn and they're
also labeled except reject based on
whether the state is acceptable or
rejected
so then this graph becomes this graph
now from the literature especially from
grace and rubenstein we know that the
optimal solution
for the delegation problem is
deterministic so in an optimal solution
or there is an optimal solution
where the receiver labels each signal
uh deterministically whether he accepts
or rejects
right so in our representation here that
means that
the receiver essentially labels each
vertex either
acceptable or rejectable so either a or
r
so let's assume he does that for
instance like this
so here this signal becomes accept
signal these two become
reject signals now given this labeling
the sender plays the best response
and has an incentive to assign
as much probability as many states of
the world to the accept signals as
possible to send these except
signals as often as possible so what the
sender will do it will assign
edges to a vertices whenever possible
all right so
all of these edges here the point 2.1.4
they all going to be assigned to this
vertex which means that in these states
of the world
is going to send this accept signal here
for this state of the world
he doesn't have an incident except
signal so all he can do is send a reject
signal
all right okay so this is what the
sender is doing
now what's the what's the objective of
the receiver what's the
what's the objective function here is of
course his utility
and his utility now is the weight of all
except edges with at least one incident
a vertex
plus the weight of all the reject edges
with two incident r vertices
right so obviously
the sender tries to send the accept
signals as often as possible and that's
fine as long as there are acceptable
states of nature
right so for these states of nature it's
actually fine to send a signal because
they get correctly classified then
for this state of nature the receiver
would prefer to get a reject signal
obviously
but since the sender maximizes the
accept probability this will be
wrongly classified here these state will
also be correctly classified because it
will go to a
where we assign the reject signal and
then sort of the
receiver takes the reject action so this
is correct as well
right so after going through all this
reasoning we see that we now
putting ourselves into the shoes of the
receiver want to label
all the vertices in a way
to maximize this objective function to
maximize the weight of all except edges
with at least one a vertex with that
line at least green vertex
plus or reject edges with two incident r
vertices
okay so how do we do this well
a way to do this or a way to formulate
this optimization problem is
the following integer program now here
we assign for every state slash vertex a
number
uh x i and x is minus one if the signal
becomes an accept signal if the receiver
does accept in the signal and it's plus
one if the receiver does reject
and then we can go through this equation
here and see what happens and we see
that for these acceptable states of
nature
this expression here becomes four
exactly when at least one of the
incident
signals is an accept signal so if at
least one of x i or x j is minus one
then this thing here becomes a four
otherwise it becomes a zero
same thing over here or according thing
over here
where we have the rejectable states of
nature and this becomes
four exactly when both of these
x i and x j are plus one so both
incidence signals are reject
signals otherwise it becomes zero
all right and then we divide this by one
one over four here and then we have the
probability mass of the correctly
correctly classified accept states and
the probability amounts of the correctly
classified reject states
okay so we don't solve this integer
program directly
instead we come up with an sdp
relaxation
and so we solve this sdp we round the
solution to an integral one
so here what we do is we adapt rounding
techniques that have been developed for
sdps
for instance for the max d card problem
or the max2 sub problem
these are the corresponding references
so here we need to adapt these
techniques
and these techniques have certain
parameters and we
did an extensive search in the parameter
space
and proved that with these parameters
that we found essentially by root for
search
uh our algorithm has an approximation
ratio of 1.1
at most right so it's not clear whether
this is tight
whether this is the best ratio so this
is the best we could find
using these techniques and a pretty
exhaustive
search in the parameter space
okay so this was essentially all that i
wanted to talk about so let me conclude
so what we study is an elementary
scenario persuasion with signals
restricted to evidence
we show algorithms for computing
sequential equilibria
efficiently and we also show
approximation algorithms when
agents have commitment power and in
terms of
approximation this is the general
picture that we have
so the persuasion problem seems to be
generally harder to approximate than the
delegation problem
but also the delegation problem is hard
in general
up to trivial factors and we identified
a number of structural conditions under
which we can show improved approximation
results
and that was it thanks for watching